My children, I have one question to ask of you.
Can nuns have coffee?
Down the hedge!
Coffee isn't restricted.
Let's go!
Amen!
Welcome to church, everybody.
Today, in my church, we talk about...
We worship more in this church.
Why is my tongue coming out?
I think I got the devil in me.
Begone, beast!
Begone!
The power of this plastic cross compels you!
Deliver us from this freakness.
Amen.
Can I get an amen?
No!
Welcome back, master and princess!
Thank you for the gifted!
Welcome, everybody, to faith!
The unholy trinity.
Except, well, it is a trinity, but we're gonna be playing one or two games today.
We'll see how I'm feeling.
Oh my goodness, so many people!
Thank you!
Why does my tongue keep coming out?
I can't keep it in!
I need to be baptized.
In the fluids of a lovely scent.
Like
a bath bomb.
Fun!
Thanks for the tag, gifted!
Hallelujah!
Cooper Black, thanks for the tag, gifted!
Thank you, Exit Mint!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Exit Mint!
That's me, but it's also you!
Happy birthday to you!
Yeah, I don't know.
This morning, well, last night I went to bed with a headache and I woke up with the same headache.
Icky.
Yeah, we hate that.
But...
I'm feeling okay now, but just in case.
I might feel better later and we can do games 1 and 2.
So, we'll see, we'll see, we'll see.
But other than that, I'm feeling so good.
Yeah, I'm feeling...
My debut is in one week and I still need two things for it.
They're pretty big things, but they're getting worked on.
Hopefully, they're done in time.
My profile picture terrifies me.
Why?
It's just a silhouette.
What?
Is it like a shadow ghost is what you're thinking of, maybe?
Rest well, Sister Mint.
Thank you.
Sister, I've always wanted a brother.
I've always wanted a brother.
Oh, gosh.
Does anyone know if the VIP tickets for the concert sold out?
Carl, that's a great question!
That's a great question.
There was like some issue with the ticket website.
It's not on, apparently, OshieSpark's end.
And OshieSpark double checked with them to make sure everything was good.
Boo!
We hate ticket websites!
They're always so bad.
So, I'm so sorry if you could not get a VIP ticket.
I'm so, so sorry.
But there will be some more releasing tomorrow.
I believe tomorrow morning.
So, they're not entirely gone.
I think that's... I don't know the time.
I'm so sorry, but...
Check OshieSpark on Twitter for the time.
Yeah, yeah.
Can't wait to watch you perform in Atlanta.
Also, one week until 3.0.
Thanks for Atlanta!
Oh, my gosh, congrats on getting the VIP!
So, 10 AM EST?
Okay.
So, it is 10 AM EST, same time as today.
So, hopefully...
Hopefully, if you did not get one today, you can get one tomorrow.
Wow!
GooseDefend!
Thanks for the perk!
Not sure if you'll be streaming this weekend, but if you do, I'll do a bust-in in advance.
Time to take a rest from your migraine I'm spending this weekend in Vermont.
First time in America outside of Florida.
And before everyone chants, USA!
USA!
I hope you... Oh, my gosh, Vermont is so beautiful.
I hope you love it.
Mandy!
Thanks for the 20 gifted!
I should be streaming this weekend.
Wait...
Like...
Like 26, 27?
Yeah, I'm streaming.
I have a schedule.
According to the schedule, you are...
Yeah, on Saturday, I'm finishing Devil May Cry.
Sunday, I'm doing a karaoke relay.
And I'm also playing Astro Bot.
So, I'm very excited.
Oh, my gosh, I'm out this weekend.
Yippee!
I'm so excited.
Oh, my gosh.
Joey!
Welcome to Mambo Shabang!
Do you know any Latin or Romance language at all, Minto?
Why is my tongue coming out?
That's my Romance language.
Hold on, give me a second.
Maybe I need to reset my pace.
I...
I need to... It's like...
What's those things where it's like...
I have to write on the chalkboard.
I will not be freaky.
Freak is my Romance language.
How's the music, by the way?
I've been talking over it.
But let me know if it's been too loud or not.
I forgot.
Yeah, the Bart Simpson's meme.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, there we go.
Sorry, I could not remember his name for a second.
It's a bit loud.
Look at this.
It's at 50%.
Maybe that's better.
I had to turn it down so much.
Loud game.
But yeah, so...
Yeah.
I hope you guys are doing well.
What's today?
Thursday.
It's Thursday, my dudes.
And we are playing Faze!
Yippee!
Let's get started.
Chapter 1, chapter 2, chapter 3.
Marathon.
All three chapters in one session.
See if I were endurance.
Hang on.
Get your mortises ready.
No, I'm gonna game.
Joy!
Thanks for the 50!
You'll get... what's this?
Oh, notes.
Thank you for singing.
Happy birthday to me.
You made me really happy.
Really love this game series.
I hope you like it.
Thank you!
I have played it once before.
Wow, there's so many different modes.
Flashlight mode, lantern mode, turbo...
It's so quiet now.
How do I flash?
Flash, flash, flash.
Have you forgotten already?
This forest has a mind of its own.
If you get lost, you could always try remembering where you've been.
I've been chatting with A.I.
Minto.
But like...
She...
She doesn't get you like I do.
Right?
You're just like, oh yeah, A.I.
Minto, but...
Repent.
Hey, I got nothing on real Minto.
Yeah?
What is this parasocialness?
Okay, Anthony, that's rich coming from you.
You...
You're just like, oh, I'm gonna crawl in there and die.
Yeah, well, you know, just because I'm not as boobielicious as Matara, okay?
I mean...
If you crawled in where I am, you would have more room.
Probably.
If everybody crawled in, everybody would be able to have their own like...
Plot of land, probably.
You know, doesn't that sound nice too?
You're not on top of each other.
Right?
Instead of being all cramped and smushed and on top of everybody.
Yeah, everybody would have space to own their own real estate, basically.
There's enough space in there for everybody, probably.
You know?
I blocked Matara-Kan until the end of the month, so I don't have to see her profile picture anymore.
When I haven't told her, so I don't know if she'll ever notice.
Anyway, she hates Mata.
I have to block her.
It's for the bit.
I don't know what she's yapping about.
I just want to show my love for Min.
Thank you.
I've joined the club of wisps in their 30s today.
May I get a birthday song as well?
Noah!
Happy birthday to you.
You are kind of old.
But welcome to the old club.
Happy birthday, Noah.
Happy birthday.
It's been a while since I've been able to properly watch one of your streams since I moved to Japan.
Inspired by me.
I'm glad I can catch one before I go to work today.
Thank you for being so awesome.
Good luck with work, Doki.
Alright, let's keep playing game, guys.
Let's keep playing game.
Min is far from small.
I mean, I would like to say that I am the medium premium.
Right?
I believe in...
Well, I mean, any size is a prize, I will always say.
But uh...
Um...
You know...
You haven't seen 3.0 yet.
And um...
So...
I might have had to fight my mama.
They were like...
But...
I love drawing boobs.
I was like, you can!
And if you draw with the big boobs, it's like an isekai version.
Maybe.
So...
You know...
So, you know, everybody who draws me always draws me with such big boobs, but that's never been the case ever.
I don't understand how it happened.
Anyway...
Where was I?
Oh, I'm reading this note, you guys.
Come on, stop talking.
Why are you guys being such freaks?
Talking about my chest, it's so weird.
We're...
We are...
We are reading.
It's good for your brain to read.
We saw your Lilith post.
If you think about it...
Amatara would be Morrigan and I would be Lilith.
It's like the same...
Body type, I would think.
Where was I?
Oh, I'm gonna start over.
Okay.
Oh gosh, maybe the coffee was a bad idea.
I'm feeling it.
I thought we were supposed to talk about your butt normally.
Yeah!
Well, not right now.
We're playing a game.
Have you forgotten already?
See?
Even the game is calling us out.
Have you forgotten already that you're playing a game?
Please.
Please remember.
You're playing a game.
This forest has a mind of its own.
If you get lost, you could always try remembering where you've been.
Pressing the escape key or start button is a good place to start.
If you're in a hurry, hold spacebar or the action button.
To skip cutscenes.
This was...
Not as...
Like...
Lory than I thought.
Here we go.
Oh my gosh, I didn't think the demons came out so fast.
Do you remember?
Get out of here.
Yeah, yeah, get out of here.
Oh.
A well.
Hello?
Oh gosh!
Hey, I was busy here.
We're closer to your heart.
Come celebrate Nate and Jason's 6th birthday.
Saturday, May 3rd.
12PM to 4PM.
Turn right at 1338...
Snakeman.
I will be freaky.
Had to spam refresh the page, but I was lucky enough to get VIP tickets.
Yippee!
I was so happy.
Congrats!
Go straight past the well.
Oh, we can go straight past the well.
Perfect.
Oh gosh.
Straight past the well.
It's locked.
How do I get in?
Excuse me.
Is there a back door?
Luckily, this cross doubles as a lockpick.
Okay.
Nevermind.
Is there a key under this rock?
I thought about getting lockpicked.
Lockpick certified.
So I can do lockpicking streams.
Hey!
Give me the key!
What did he say?
That's...
Maybe the key is here.
Lockpicking streams.
Yeah, why not?
Oh, this one.
Oh my goodness.
Mr. Martin.
It has taken longer than expected registering the markers on your property as a historical cemetery.
Our office had difficulty identifying who was buried there.
The inscriptions on the gravestones are written in a language that we cannot identify.
I've sent the gravestone rubbings to some of my peers at the University of Connecticut.
I will reach out to you when I get a response from there.
All the best.
Daryl Henderson, State of Connecticut Historical Society
Yeah.
I will become a lockpicking master and then you better watch out.
Daryl sucks at his job.
Just Google it.
Just Google the name.
Ok, hold on.
It's a little loud.
Map!
That's so cute.
Barabash!
Thanks for the superchat!
Thank you!
Haunted rubble.
Public lecture.
By Carl James Osborne.
Connecticut's historical connections to witchcraft, satanism, and the beast system.
Wednesday 8pm.
But where?
Where, Carl?
You forgot the most important part!
Carl's like, At your mom's house.
The beast system.
My favorite OS.
He's like, I'll tell you how to be a beast.
With your mom.
Gary loves you.
Are you still coming after me?
Haunted puddle!
Real.
Haunted puddle real.
I caught some people walking through the woods around the house last week.
Not kids.
Just regular adults.
I don't think they're regular then.
They told me they got lost while hiking.
I pointed them back towards the road.
The whole thing just didn't feel right.
I think I should go dig up Bob's rifle out of storage.
Where am I?
Oh, the puddle is not important.
It's important enough to be put on the map, I guess.
Gary loves you.
Another house.
Oh my goodness.
The Martin's house lies about 100 yards off of Snake Meadow Hill Road.
There is almost no driveway.
Trees jut out in the middle of a gravel path that is mostly covered in grass.
It was difficult to find the house, especially since it was already dark when we arrived.
Father Allred seemed to know where he was going.
He simply drove straight ahead until we arrived at the house.
In the headlights, I saw an old shed off to the right of the path.
Father Allred explained that he would rather perform the exorcism away from the house.
But the Martin's had insisted that Amy remain inside.
He complained that having the family present makes it difficult to proceed with elements of the rite that may seem harsh to the layperson.
Lockpicking stream would be interesting to see as I am a locksmith.
Really?
Well, I'd want to get... Like I said, I'd want to get certified first.
Certify...
Freak.
7 days a week.
Spoopy Atari game.
Can't wait for the 31st.
Me too!
Thanks Chucky!
That was a close one, wasn't it?
Now how do I get back?
Quickdraw.
Deer.
I bet the wells...
I hope it's not that way.
What is this?
You can get transparent locks to practice with at home.
They're really fun to play with.
Really?
Bob, the kids and I miss you more every day.
The twins and Amy have started their next school year here at home.
Amy keeps asking when she's going to be allowed to go to real school.
Real school.
I think she's getting cabin fever.
The twins are having no problems occupying their time.
Yesterday they came in with their hands covered in blood.
Oh my god!
Oh those silly twins.
Oh David and Eli.
They're just running around covering their hands in blood.
Silly silliness.
Yeah, you know how kids are.
Gosh.
Have I ever told you guys?
One time I was at a store.
And I was just browsing.
This was quite recent actually.
Like a couple months ago.
I was just browsing.
There was like a dad and his two kids that were nearby.
And they were like looking at stuff near me.
And then I hear the dad say...
Come on, let's go Dave and Eli.
And I was...
It was like a fight or flight reaction.
It wasn't David.
It was Dave.
But I was like no.
There's no way.
There's actually no way that these two kids next to me were named Dave and Eli.
They're right.
But like what are the chances?
What are the chances?
Right?
It took me a minute.
My brain immediately activated.
I just asked that dad.
No.
I couldn't imagine just like...
Are your children Metal Gear children?
Do you think they're younger than MGSV?
When did that come out?
They were probably like 7.
Does that make the dad a big boss?
I think so.
It's been 9 years?
Insane.
Should've asked if the children were terrible.
The twins are having no problems occupying their time.
Yesterday they came in with their hands covered in blood.
I guess they found a dead deer and thought it would be a good idea to touch it.
I think we might have a coyote problem because...
When I went out with them to look at the dead deer, it was a pretty gruesome sight.
All this just a day after the twins' birthday party.
Can't wait till you come home.
Oh, I thought he was dead.
Did you know your kids are a Metal Gear reference?
Don't come this way.
Hey deer, can you lead me to the well, please?
This way?
OK.
Where is the well?
Deer?
Won't you be a deer and take me to the well, please?
Be a deer.
Oh gosh!
Hey!
Oh, this is... OK.
So we need to go up.
OK.
Thanks, deer.
Dead tree.
Oh, we found something new though.
This is good.
Ghost tree.
Today I noticed Amy's favorite tree looks like it's dying.
All the needles are falling off of it.
Off it and the bark is peeling.
I saw a clip from a reality TV show of some guy who wanted to name his kids after Elden Ring bosses.
I mean, there's children named Sephiroth out there.
Just think about that.
I guess I'm more upset about it than Amy is.
She's totally absorbed in her volunteer work at the clinic.
I guess it's good that she found something she's passionate about.
But I've gotten really... I've gotten ugly looks from some of the women at book club.
What?
Cathy and her religious friends won't even talk to me anymore.
She's volunteering at a clinic!
What is the issue?
Father Sephiroth.
What's wrong with it?
She's at a clinic!
Haunted blood.
Just kidding.
It talks.
I understand now.
Chaos reigns.
I'm lost again you guys.
Oh no.
I think I need to go over one.
I think he went after... We found it!
Let's go.
He keeps trying to get me, but I'm too fast.
I'm a speedy guy.
Too fast for you.
Let's go.
Enter the house.
It's an achievement I got.
Mr. and Mrs. Martin greeted us at the front porch.
Mr. Martin led us downstairs to the basement, explaining that Amy was down there in restraint.
I felt for him.
There was guilt and shame in his voice.
Amy was in the very back of the attic in a...
Wait, huh?
I thought Amy was in the basement.
Amy was in the very back of the attic in a chair, perfectly calm, staring at us.
It is hard to describe the look on her face.
It was not the kind of look a child gives you.
Freaky kid.
Such a sweet family.
Where are your twins though?
They hate the twins.
David and Eli...
They suck.
It's really quiet in here guys.
It's a sunny day.
It's a beautiful day.
Whatever this is, we don't care about it.
Cute.
I want a nice picture.
We can't go outside.
It's really quiet.
Haunted plant!
It's been a long time since I've played this game, so I can't quite remember all the stuff.
So...
I'll do my best.
Haunted mirror!
Oh my gosh, there is something behind me!
Haunted bed!
This bed needs to be christened.
Haunted dresser.
Okay, let's go upstairs.
Wait.
I have to have faith.
I know, gosh, the atmosphere in this is too good.
It freaks me out.
It's too good, because it's just...
The lack of atmosphere is everything, you know what I mean?
You don't need the atmosphere.
You don't need all the scary music.
Freaky toys!
This one is haunted.
No.
Okay.
We're fine.
Everything is good.
Oh, that freaky ghost.
Bob must be stationed somewhere in the Middle East, because he sent over this weird looking doll for Amy's birthday.
I'll ask Anisha about it next time we have book club.
She looks like she could be from over there.
Okay, we're assuming.
Amy didn't seem excited to see the doll.
I think she would rather have a phone instead.
Or maybe seeing a baby doll makes her feel self-conscious about working at the clinic.
I guess I was the only one who thought to check in the attic.
When I got up there, it was freezing cold.
First sign of a ghost!
First sign of a ghost.
I found Amy standing in the back, looking straight at me, like when I first met her downstairs.
Beware the temptation.
What temptation?
The serpent?
And it's venom will send you an inescapable curse of brain rot?
I have too much brain rot.
Too much brain rot.
First ghost, bottom right.
Pazuzu doll!
Oh my gosh, my icon!
Pazuzu.
Well, we spoke briefly, although it was frustrating to talk to her.
Or it.
I experienced a bit of deception from the demon.
During our conversation, she uttered my mother's first name and in other instances, spoke perfect Latin.
I called for help from the others, but nobody came.
So I raised my crucifix and began the rite again.
That's the rite.
Haunted Ducky!
Good luck with the busting.
Thank you!
I don't feel safe in my own home anymore.
I hear voices outside around the house at night.
I don't let the twins go out in the woods to play because I'm afraid of what's out there.
The house itself feels stressed, distorted, slanted somehow.
It's like I'm walking through a carnival funhouse.
Amy's condition has only gotten worse.
I can't stand to be around her and I don't know why.
She just doesn't seem like herself anymore.
I want to take her to the doctor, but I can't leave the boys here.
I find that the phone stops working throughout the day.
And now I can't seem to find my car keys!
Thank god Bob comes home tomorrow.
The power of Minto compels you!
OK, we had this door over here.
Oh, I don't think... OK, we gotta go into the basement first.
Alrighty, righty!
DORIME!
Does anybody remember DORIME?
I don't remember how.
I just remember the DORIME part.
Sorry.
Into the basement!
Don't like that.
D-d-d-dum!
With my cross I'm all powerful!
Oh.
Oh!
Haunted...
Haunted bench.
Dear Amy, thanks for writing!
It really brightened my day hearing from you.
In your letter you asked, what's the weirdest thing I've seen as a missionary.
The area we are working in has a lot of folks who practice...
Quim-bamba.
It's what you might call a pagan religion.
It's kind of a mix of Catholic and African religions.
One of the saints they worship is San La Muerte.
Or Saint Death.
Hi ghost lady.
Hello!
Yesterday we talked to a boy about 15.
When we asked him if he had ever prayed, he said, No, but I have prayed to San La Muerte.
He told us about a time when he stayed over at his cousin's house and according to him, they prayed to some figures of San La Muerte and the figures made things in the house move around!
He got real quiet and scared looking after that.
We told him he could pray to God and that God wouldn't make him feel scared like that.
We invited him to church, but he hasn't come yet.
I need to wrap this letter up and get back to work.
He prayed.
He never prayed, but he prayed.
He's busy.
Yeah, this is a busy guy.
I gotta get back to work now.
Girl!
See you in 4 months!
Layton.
Of the Professor variety or Haunted Laundry.
Haunted Puddle.
No Haunted Puddle.
Making my way.
Oh, I don't like those.
I don't like those at all.
Making my way through the basement.
Freaked out by all the mannequins.
Oh, let's get this first.
Amy's parents could not endure witnessing the proceedings of the rite for long.
Mrs. Martin was hysterical, and the thing that was inside Amy was feeding off of the fear.
Father Allred asked me to take the Martins upstairs.
I was physically worn out, but managed to get them back up the stairs.
Into the kitchen.
Amy was screaming, Mother!
Mother!
The whole time.
Finally, I got them to sit down with me at the kitchen table.
After a few minutes, we couldn't hear much of anything down in the basement, so I went down to check on things.
I found Father Allred lying on his back, unconscious, with his arms spread out wide.
Amy was not in the chair.
That can't be good.
I don't think so.
Oh boy.
Good morning meantime!
No!
Oh my gosh.
No, I didn't mean to skip it.
No!
I was holding up my cross.
I'm so sorry you guys.
I'm so sorry.
I forgot that skip is now space.
Apparently that's a new thing.
She is here!
Ah!
Oh, I got her immediately.
Nice.
Okay, so we need to go back.
We need to somehow find the...
Can we go in here yet?
No.
We need to find the key.
Exercise the cutscene.
I was just trying to hold up my...
my cross.
Die for the first time?
Big Pazuzu, come in.
Kazuhiro Miller.
How did I die?
Oh, here we go.
We get to see her for real now.
Mortis.
She is here!
Do I go grab the gun?
I'm trying to remember what to do here.
I'm too fast for you.
How did she catch me though?
That was so close.
I saw her little prints on the carpet.
It's hard to see though.
Maybe that's what I missed before and she got on top of me.
Run, run, run!
Run, run.
Oh!
Got her.
Can I...
Ok, I can't change direction when I have the cross on.
Oh, I see her.
I see her coming.
Do I need to be down here?
Or am I crazy?
I don't think I need to be down here.
Ma'am!
You gotta commit.
I gotta commit to whatever.
Can I get to that sewing machine?
Oh my god!
That was so close!
Holy moly!
Oh no, there is nothing here.
Ok.
That was so close.
We got this.
Um, though...
I'm running.
I didn't even know she was there.
I just thought it was the manne...
I was like that mannequin is looking awfully sus.
It's my sixth sense!
She can't fool a ghost.
Mammy!
Do I leave now?
No!
Mortis!
Dang it.
Mortis.
The carpet is murder.
For real, actually!
If I get too close to the door, will she kill me?
She is here.
Well, I need to poop.
Oh, so does she apparently.
Holy cow!
You failed me?
She is here.
Forsaken!
Forsaken?
I don't remember this part, you guys.
Goodness gracious.
Sometimes she is so close.
Mammy!
Is it in here?
Look at me.
We got it!
I think I need to exorcise her in like a bunch of the rooms.
OK, nice.
Does that mean she is gone?
There is no music anymore.
Am I safe?
Door-tis.
OK.
Alright.
To the attic we go.
Oh my gosh.
I love this episode of Mad Libs.
It's literally like Clue.
Where is she?
In the candlestick?
In the kitchen?
When I confronted her, she...
Managed to cut the power to the house and...
Her own parents.
With their own...
Oh my goodness.
I have to go back to that house.
The nightmares I'm having are real.
She is still there waiting for me.
I can still help her.
If I don't come back, know that I love you and I'm sorry.
John.
Safe.
Save.
What happened to you?
Do you think my face is pretty?
I have to finish what I started.
She's been alone?
Possessed by a demon?
For a year?
What do you mean what happened to your face?
What's wrong with your face?
What's that guy?
Oh don't skip.
What's wrong with your face?
Time...
Got her.
Mortis.
The rotoscope parts are just too cool.
Why was I facing the wrong way?
Do I have to dodge?
Do I dodge instead?
And I'll getcha!
Oh nice.
Oh, where is she?
And I'll getcha!
Wait a...
Round 2!
Oh my gosh.
I don't remember how to do this part.
Oh my goodness.
Mortis.
Oopsie.
At least they are nice enough to give you this checkpoint.
You know?
I don't think she is able to be touched here.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, she can be touched.
Nevermind.
Dang it.
OK.
We got this.
No worries.
Don't touch me.
Oh.
More.
I can't dodge.
Wait, can she touch me here?
Hold on.
I'm going to experiment.
Oh.
OK.
Well, that's not exactly what I was trying to see.
More.
Hurt me mortis.
Like, this is what I want to see.
OK.
I got it now.
Acquired a ticket.
Help me get some time to do some 3AM Waffle House.
Oh boy.
I'm going to get beat up at the Waffle House.
Or see some of Atlanta's scenic tumbleweaves.
Like the desert?
Isn't that a tumble wave?
I'm scared.
I'm going to...
I'm scared of when she starts coming at me.
She goes in the same way every time, but...
Oh my gosh.
Sorry guys, I'm not very good at this part.
I'm not very good at this.
I think I'm struggling a little bit.
I don't know how to draw a star apparently.
Oh gosh.
I don't know how to draw a star.
And I'm kind of slow.
And she is really fast.
More.
OK.
We got to the third point.
So maybe we will be alright.
OK.
Then she starts going.
Oh no.
Oh my gosh.
I was so close.
Guys, I was so close.
And I can't be... Oh, in the circle.
Circle.
That she creates.
She is bleeding.
I give up.
I got run over by a man.
This part is scary.
Where did that guy come from?
The pattern is the pentagram.
I know, but I can't... I don't know how to draw a star.
And it's upside down.
So it's kind of like...
Freaky.
And then she goes down in the middle.
And then she goes over.
And I can attack.
I don't know.
From here I'm lost.
And then she goes up.
And then I can attack.
Oh goodness.
Is it here?
Oh god.
OK.
Mortis.
Who just gifted?
Jobless?
Don't gift if you are jobless.
Thanks for the five gifted though.
But don't do it if you are jobless.
Take care of yourself.
Thank goodness.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my god.
I wasn't aligned.
Guys, I'm so sorry.
I'm really bad at this part.
Can I just like chill here?
Oh OK.
I'm not...
I'm too far away.
Dang it!
No!
Where is she coming down?
OK.
This is not going so high, but that's OK.
And then she's going to go over here.
OK.
Shoot.
And then over here.
Where did she stop?
Oh.
She was waiting for me.
Did she go in the middle?
OK.
Now she's just repeating.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
I wasn't aligned.
Which means now she'll go up here.
That guy's got a little face on him now.
The crosses are back to normal.
OK.
She ran outside, so we're safe.
Nice fight, Mito.
Thank you.
Kill her.
What do you mean thank you?
Lembas takes you three months.
Lick.
Shoot the mirror.
I've never seen that ending.
Does it actually shoot?
Does it actually work?
One shot.
It does.
The mirror works.
I don't think I remember...
Wait.
Can I go back inside?
OK.
Good.
Shrimp!
Thanks for the five gifted.
Was it upstairs or downstairs?
It's a secret.
Shoot the mirror.
I don't think I've ever seen it before.
There was a thing behind me.
Wait,
it gives me another gun.
Eating Mike Tyson's...
Thanks for the five gifted.
Do it again?
OK.
Thanks guys.
I had no idea about this.
Thanks for the five gifted.
OK, let's try it again.
Let's try it again.
A gun with one bullet.
Bullet.
OK.
I don't like this.
Why did you...What's wrong with you guys?
Wait, why did you send me here?
I'm not lined up.
I hate when I'm not facing the right direction.
Come!
I did...
Find and defeat the secret boss of chapter one.
Oh my god, scary!
Scary!
You guys should have warned me!
Oh my gosh!
October 23rd.
That was yesterday!
1986.
Dear Dr. Mcglashon.
It has been 30 days since the beginning of my treatment here at Yale Psychiatric Institute.
Dr. Spinell, who has been so patient with me, has helped me understand my afflictions and has helped me find a way to move forward and accept the truth.
With Dr. Spinell's help, I have come to accept what really happened in September at the Martin family residence.
I accept that what happened was not the result of any supernatural phenomenon, but rather the desperate actions of a young girl driven to violence by her dogmatic parents and old church rituals that are thought to drive out evil.
I am happy to report that since accepting the truth, my nightmares have ceased and I now enjoy peace of mind that I have not felt since the incident.
Given my progress since first coming here, I respectfully request my release from Yale Psychiatric Institute, contingent upon follow-up appointments with Dr. Spinell in the future.
Sincerely, John Ward I think he's a liar!
You liar!
Can we go back in there?
Excuse me.
There's no reflection.
John Faith!
A gun with one bullet.
What should I kill?
Her?
I guess I have to.
At this point she's probably just like a rotting corpse, right?
Hello?
Is anybody...
I was going to say alive, but...
I'm so scared.
Don't be scared!
Happy six months.
Thanks for the six months!
Hunt the deer?
Hello?
Is any...
Who is that?
I always shoot first.
Ask questions later.
Get off my property.
Who is that?
I think I can get another gun.
I'll hunt down every damn thing in this forest.
Even if it's the last thing I do.
Wait, this looks like a trail.
I think I...
I commit to my actions.
I commit to my actions!
We're fine.
Probably.
Yeah, it's time to get out of here.
Let's go back home.
John Faith waddles off into the sunset.
Who is that guy?
Probably the bad guy.
Probably.
Oopsie.
I shall not be afraid.
Two of five.
Father and son.
I fight against the enemy at such a critical time.
There is another reason why I dare not return Michael to his family, nor let them see him.
The darkness inside him afflicts his soul, but it also causes a terrible strain on his body.
So that there may be no mistaking what I mean, I have enclosed a photograph of young Michael during one of our sessions.
The photograph is missing.
New background, new effect and new play mode.
What did I do?
I didn't do anything.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Should we try for... I don't have to play the whole game again to get the other endings, right?
Welcome back!
Thank you!
It's saved at the end?
OK, cool.
What I started...
Has not been approved by the Vatican!
I said the thing!
The 21st of September?
21st of September Do you remember?
21st of September Do you remember the 21st?
Alright, so...
I have begin, but I don't have a continue.
Maybe if I click begin.
What's the extras though?
It said I got a new play mode.
Oh, replay intro.
Conjuration mode, coming soon.
Survival mode.
Chapter 1, chapter 2, chapter 3.
Who's this one?
Chapter 3?
Just saying it like that, 119 more times.
Oh,
chapter...
Oh, that's right!
I was thinking, like, when it saves.
You're so right.
I don't have the backgrounds enabled, but I want to see what the other background is that we got.
Oh, it's this one!
I'm kind of covering it, it's kind of moved over.
I feel like the backgrounds...
I don't want to say ruin the vibes, but...
Like, I don't want to see anime priests...
While I'm... You know?
Like, it's just kind of...
This is so funny.
Chapter 1.
We got 8 out of 20?
There's so many notes!
Oh no, sorry, 18 out of 20.
I was going to say, wowie.
Okay.
When can we expect to play HuniePop?
I don't know, I've played HuniePop before.
A gun with one bullet.
Seriously, Salvo, welcome to...
Mambo Ship.
Wait, all these trees, where did they come from?
I just noticed.
I'm so happy my first in-person concert gets to be you and Doki.
The venue is only a 5-hour drive from me, so I pulled the trigger this morning and committed.
Wow, Pac-Man!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, see you there!
Just curious, do you do the goofy scream intentionally or does it come out naturally?
What's goofy about my scream?
What do you mean?
I think I found her.
My scream isn't that goofy!
Is it?
That's a weird tree.
Isn't there a deer that I can shoot?
What if I get really close to her?
Ma'am?
Put your hands up.
Why are her arms like that?
Oh
my gosh.
We love Goofy Minto screams.
I mean Disney Goofy.
Disney Goofy scream.
Where he goes like...
How does a Goofy scream sound like?
That one?
Every time I think of Goofy screams, sometimes my brain inputs the...
The Wilhelm scream instead.
It's this guy!
What if we go talk to him?
Ok, who are you?
Hey, who are you mister?
Oh my god, I didn't actually expect him to respond.
Greetings from Hakone!
There is a great juxtaposition with this stream and my Ryokan playing calming piano music in the dining hall.
Are you forcing everybody to listen?
Oh,
I found the deer.
Ok, don't run, don't run.
If I get close to it, it will run, right?
If I get close to it, it will run.
You got scared of a guy with a shotgun, fair.
True.
Ok, I gotta line this up.
Don't look up, deer.
Ok, you go that way, I'll go this way.
3 steps, turn around.
It's gonna feel bad.
It was right on top of him.
You're a ghost and an exorcist?
It's complicated.
Is the deer gonna attack me this time?
Oh my god, this is so brutal.
Wait, we actually hit a tree, not the deer at all.
4 of 5.
The Hunter.
Over the Hedge remake is getting pretty metal.
Unidentified body discovered near wrecked car.
The site of a deadly car accident was discovered along a road near Sterling this morning.
Along with the body of a person who has not yet been identified.
At 6am this morning, a resident called to report an accident along Snake Meadow Hill Road.
The driver of a silver sedan has swerved off the road and struck a tree.
A spokesman for the police commented that the body appeared to have been dragged several yards away from the car deeper into the woods after having been ejected from the front windshield.
It was noted that the body had been mangled beyond recognition.
Investigators suspect this was probably the work of coyotes.
Police also noted that parts of a cleaned white-tailed deer were found in the trunk of the car.
From a white-tailed deer, a hunter typically gets 75 pounds of meat.
However, it appears that the victim of the accident was only able to carry 25 pounds back to the car.
Oh, is it Oregon Trail reference?
Mortis.
Bambi's Revenge.
Real.
Oh, that's so funny.
Okay, let's get the other endings.
Dysentery.
A gun with one bullet.
Okay, what are the other two endings though?
We got the one with the guy, we got the one with the deer, and I know where she is.
What other endings could there be?
Except if there's five.
American emphasis on coyote.
A coyote.
Find the squirrel?
There's a squirrel.
We love rain of spiders.
Rain of spiders!
Okay, I can just leave.
It looks like from top down, it looks like a really long cigarette.
Well, nevermind.
I just shot the deer.
I guess I can just leave since we are here.
Let's try that one.
Did he say...aww bummer.
Oh father!
Father!
I thought he went...aww bummer!
That's the guy that attacked me in the backseat.
He's able to finish his little monologue.
This is the canon ending.
Ending 5 of 5, when faith endures.
Alright.
Oh, police.
Animal experts investigate chupacabra remains found near Sterling.
Sterling PD is enlisting the help of local animal experts from the University of Connecticut after the remains of an unidentified animal were found near Sterling.
The remains of an animal, which some residents are calling a chupacabra, were discovered on Snake Meadow Hill Road by a motorist yesterday.
The animal had apparently been struck by a vehicle and parts of its carcass were scattered across the road.
Police say they initially investigated the gruesome scene because the motorist who discovered the remains had told them they appeared to be of a person.
After arriving at the scene, the police concluded that the remains were of some kind of an animal.
As a matter of public safety, we want to be sure about what exactly we're dealing with here, said a Sterling police spokesman.
This is clearly not a deer or a coyote.
If it's a mountain lion or exotic pet that escapes from its owners or an animal with rabies, we need to know about it.
Oh my gosh.
You know what scares me so much is our like animal diseases.
Okay, so like, have you guys seen like the neurological diseases that happen in like animals sometimes?
Like, you'll see like deer that will like fall on their back and like just start like kicking in the air and things like that.
And like...
But they're so scary.
They're so scary.
Oh my gosh, rabies is so scary.
Yeah, like the zombie deer.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my gosh, it's so sad.
Prions!
Yes!
The prions!
Oh my gosh.
It's so scary.
Oh my gosh, and then you have to kill them.
You have to put them out of their misery and it's just so sad.
It's so sad.
Rabies though, if you get it, you like...
I think once you know you have it, it's like too late or something, right?
Humans, be careful, okay?
Don't get rabies.
Be careful.
Be careful, okay?
Stop petting squirrels and raccoons.
Even if they're very fluffy and cute.
I won't stop though.
I think it was a kid?
They literally described me.
Hairless, anemic and suffering from a lack of vitamin D.
Okay.
Rude.
Alright.
Let's...
I want to find the squirrel.
Oh, it's only been an hour and a half.
Okay, I think we can do episode 2 then.
One bullet.
Are you an otaku too?
So what?
It's an actual squirrel?
Here in the woods that we have to find?
Actual squirrel?
What if one of the things you had to kill was actual cannibal Shia LaBeouf?
Hairless where?
What do you mean?
Why are you asking that?
I've seen him before.
I have?
The squirrel?
I thought... or Shia LaBeouf.
Excuse me.
You're looking cute as always.
Love the thumbnail.
Thank you, Rodrigo.
I love the thumbnail too.
I remember when I first saw that picture I was like, I got to use that for Faith whenever I play it.
Actual cannibal.
Shia LaBeouf.
You're lost in the woods.
Whoa, Barry!
Did it hurt when you fell from here?
Oh no, I missed.
Just shut up.
Get out of here, Barry.
What the hell?
What are you doing here?
Is this the squirrel?
It looks kind of like a cat.
This is the thing I shoot?
It's a fox, but yes.
I'm so sorry.
His soul will be saved now.
OK, I'm scared though.
I've never seen this before.
Yonder.
Oh, that's grass.
Oh, we're at the road.
My car is...
Over yonder.
Yonder.
Oh, here we go.
Co-op, thanks for membership.
You're welcome.
Let's go.
I have nothing to say this time?
Oh my god!
The cult?
They're like you.
The offering.
I took their sacrifice.
Oh my gosh.
Did I do that?
Oh no!
If there...
Gary.
I still consider you a part of the team.
Even if your mom and dad do not.
We hope to see you there.
Gary.
Rabies has a 99.9% survival rate.
Non-survival rate.
Do you hear them?
Ah!
I think they're speaking Latin.
Spooky!
But...Paragon?
I wish.
Alright, last ending baby!
Alright, we know where she's at.
We know where she's at.
Paragon.
Paragon gun.
Sorry.
Does it come back?
Yeah, ok.
Paragon gun.
Paragon bullet.
Paragon shoot.
Paragon demon.
Alright, let's go kill a little girl.
There we go.
Thank goodness it respawns, right?
Hey girl!
Take
that demon!
Stupid demon!
You have no vessel anymore!
Idiot demon!
Dummy dummy demon.
My car is...
Yeah, we cured her.
We cured her everybody.
The fox is not here.
That's kind of crazy.
Boss, you killed a child.
Amazing.
Mission complete.
Ok, I think it's over.
One more.
And then down.
No, this way.
Ok, that was weird.
Ending 1 of 5.
Murderer!
No way!
The police, they found me so fast!
How?
I should have killed that other guy in the woods.
Find all endings of chapter 1.
Gone too far is what it's called.
Police arrest man accused of murdering missing girl.
That person!
Thanks for the time gifted!
A New York man is in custody after he confessed to the murder of a sterling girl who had been missing.
Sorry.
John Ward of Palmyra was pulled over on Snake Meadow Hill Road last night after a state trooper reported hearing a gunshot.
The officer thought it might be poachers.
I mean, have you seen?
There's a chupacabra running around the woods!
I was just doing my job!
The officer said Ward was acting nervous and suspicious after being pulled over.
When questioned, Ward reportedly said, I've killed her.
John, John, please!
According to the police report, the officer called for backup after Ward became increasingly upset, saying repeatedly that there was a demon inside her.
Ward was taken to Sterling Police Headquarters for further questioning.
Ward then confessed to authorities that he shot and killed Amy Martin, a 17-year-old girl who had been missing for 9 days after escaping from a mental institution.
Well, it's you guys' fault for, you know, not finding her soon enough.
Finders keepers, I guess.
After a brief search, police located Amy's body in the woods near the now abandoned Martin home.
In addition to receiving a gunshot wound to the stomach, Amy showed injuries suggesting that she had been thrown out of the second story window of the house.
Oh, yeah, she did that herself.
An officer who helped recover the body told reporters that Amy's face had been mutilated in a very brutal manner.
Ward was found dressed as a priest when he was pulled over.
It's his Halloween costume.
It is suspected that he impersonated a priest to gain his victim's trust after Catholic authorities in Rome confirmed that Ward was not an ordained minister.
The rest of the article is missing.
What he was about to do was not approved by the Vatican.
New play mode?
Oh, that's it?
Why is it show 3 then?
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Yay!
We got all three.
On to chapter 2?
Or should I call it here?
No...
How long would chapter 2 and 3 be?
Because they're the longest.
They're much longer, right?
Chapter 2 is also short?
Chapter 3 is very long.
Chapter 2 is about an hour and a half.
I think we can do that.
Let's do it!
Chapter 2!
New game.
Confirm.
Let me undo my pin message then.
Let's go baby.
Father Garcia, you are hereby instructed to release Michael Davies from your custody and return him to his home immediately.
Mr. and Mrs. Davies have already been contacted by our office.
A representative of the church is currently en route to their home to discuss compensation and return for their discretion.
You will meet our representative there and accompany him back to Rome.
Cardinal?
I thought that said girlfriend.
Wow, Cardinal Girlfriend!
Davies.
Wait.
Oh it's Davie Jones Locker, not Davies Jones.
Why are you a pirate?
Because I thought it was Davies Jones.
You know, I'm testing you.
Wow.
Our cross is old and orange.
And our toilet is in the same room.
Is this a studio apartment?
Shouldn't there at least be like a door for the bathroom?
In case guests come over?
One day.
One day on VTubers.
Two weeks on VTubers.
Three months on VTubers.
It's like looking in the mirror.
I'm so sorry.
I can't stop yawning you guys.
The coffee is not coffee-ing I guess.
But I'm not so tired.
I just can't stop yawning.
Oh my gosh.
I need to make you better first.
Leave you silent to the demon.
Mikey bad.
Bad, bad, bad.
Mikey...
Bad, bad.
Take that.
You were washing your mouth out with some soap.
Mikey bad.
That's a bad word Mikey.
Do you think... Do you think I should do it?
Do I have to kill him?
I feel like this is gonna...
Oh my gosh.
Is that blood all over him?
Oh, he's free.
I think we are in trouble.
Mikey?
Oh Mikey?
Can I leave?
Oh man, you made a mess of my apartment and everything.
He took his picture!
He's embarrassed.
It's an embarrassing photo from the Christmas party.
Chill!
What's that?
What's that you got there?
Who is that?
I have the body of a pig?
Who is this?
We are scampering out.
Discover Father Garcia's backstory.
3 months of hell.
It's 2 AM.
Cool.
Have you forgotten already?
The notes people leave behind seem to exist on the edges of memory.
Pressing the escape key or the start button is a good way to remember what you don't realize you have forgotten.
Wait, huh?
If you are in a hurry, hold spacebar or the action button to skip cutscenes.
Andregos!
Today is my birthday!
Glad to spend it here with you and the Wisps.
May I ask you to sing the birthday song from MGSV?
It would make my day.
Of course!
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
Happy birthday with salutations!
Happy birthday!
May your scars stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Andregos!
Happy birthday!
Yay!
Thank you!
Happy birthday!
And Zen, thanks for the superchat!
Spooky tree!
Our cross is white now.
Sorry.
Spookier tree.
It's not Christmas yet.
Notice.
The current investigation being conducted at Gallop Cele...
Gallop Cele...
Gallop Cemetery by the State of Connecticut Historical Society has been postponed until further notice.
In the interim, we ask the public to avoid the cemetery grounds, the surrounding woods, any wildlife, and any unidentified persons roaming the area.
Thank you for your patience.
I'm not listening to that.
You're reading so well.
Don't sass me.
Why are you RIP YF Onion?
To Onion Fairy, thank you!
Why did you die?
We're in the cemetery.
Maybe I should have looked around first.
Can I leave?
Thank you!
The ghost is so polite.
I'm just gonna take a little look around here.
Just gonna, you know, have a view of the area.
Are the trees all the same?
Oh, oh.
Okay, I don't think there's much to explore.
Maybe.
Maybe we have nothing to explore.
Oh wait!
Oh no, that's the first tree.
Oh, this is where I came from.
What if I go down from where I came from?
Just a stroll in the woods.
We don't know what's around here.
If I go to the left, am I at the cemetery?
Oh, no?
Okay, I think...
There's not even a map.
Yeah, we're gonna mosey on over.
Okay, okay, I don't think there's anything here.
I think we can continue onward into the cemetery.
The screens wrap around in the weirdest ways.
Sometimes.
Okay.
Let's go!
Who's this?
Mint Phantom.
And Mint Phantom's big ass.
I needed two plots.
Oh, what was that?
Oh!
I shook hands with the devil.
I looked him in the eye.
He looked like a long lost friend.
Okay.
Writing your little poetry... your lyrics.
I'll inherit his kingdom.
You must first conjure his demon.
You must then serve his demon.
You must then walk among... among... among us?
The children of men as his demon.
Thus shall you receive the blessing of the unspeakable!
Return...
In need of rest, Gary.
Unspeakable!
So this is save.
Enter the spirit house.
Hello?
Who are you?
Okay.
They are watching stream right now.
They are locked in on stream.
What is this?
Me!
I've got the key!
Are they dead or...
I can't tell if it's like blood around their necks, you know?
Maybe they are fine.
Stop!
I'm fine.
I'm good.
All the doors are open!
I don't like that.
Which one should we go in first?
I remember one of these giving me a bit of a trouble before.
Let's go up first.
Oh, I think that's the key that I needed.
Okay, let's go to the left.
The happiest gravestone ever.
Wait, one of them is pointing right.
This guy is pointing up.
This guy is pointing left.
Is it a clue?
Is this the maze part?
Oh gosh.
What is this?
Okay, but which way?
Hold on.
Do I read from right to left or left to right?
Let me hold on.
Let's go down real quick.
Whoa.
A bee!
Oh my gosh, thank you for the...
Oh my gosh, I can't see.
I can't see this kid.
Oh, thank you so much for the petting!
Oopsie, I died.
Did we get the key though?
In here.
Oh no.
Okay, so we gotta do our little creepy smile.
I got the key.
Okay, and those guys glow red.
And then I'm gonna go back in and save.
There we go, perfect.
Okay.
Oh, this kid looks like he's gonna be a little dookie head.
Oh gosh, okay.
Maybe it's up, left...
Up, right?
If we're going right to left?
Or, you know, up, left, up, right.
Or is it right, up, left, up?
Right?
Let's try right, up.
Right.
Why would you read this right to left?
Because I came in from the right!
I thought it was from the way I was facing like this, you know?
Wait, so right...
Up...
Left... Nothing's changing though.
Left...
Up...
Sorry,
that scared me really bad.
No!
Oh gosh!
I
can't get a good angle on this guy.
I'll see you again?
Creepy.
Creepy, creepy.
I've been freed!
No more overbearing father turned violent alcoholic.
No more hiding my bruises and cuts.
No more pills and needles.
Oh my goodness.
No more getting laughed at and kicked around.
They'll never laugh at me again.
By day my body withers away.
But by night my mind explores forbidden worlds of power and knowledge.
Guided by beings of pure darkness.
I have been trusted with secret knowledge of the demon's seal.
I have learned the correct conjuring sign.
Drawing the inverted star along the rocks arranged in five.
First at the top left point.
And then down.
I will lure them into the woods.
Then I will show them my power.
So can I just leave here?
Am I good now?
See ya!
Top left down?
Wait.
Wait, do I have to do more?
Ah, I think I can just leave.
I think I am finished with that, right?
Let's save.
Save.
Who is next?
Are you the child?
Are you the little guy that's gonna torment me?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, are there four or are there three?
Because there are four guys here.
Curious.
Curious, curious, curious.
What's the eyes then for?
I guess let's attempt this.
I don't like this one.
I can't see him.
Oh my gosh.
No!
I can't see this kid.
Stinking baby!
He needs to stop farting.
Oh, I wasn't lined up properly.
Oh my gosh.
Is he going in a... Oh, I see him blinking a little bit.
Sometimes.
Oh, maybe...
Wait, where the hell was he?
I don't even know.
Oh, there he is.
Oh my gosh.
Kid!
Hey kid!
Wow, this is...
Let's go check out the other area first.
What's over here instead?
Spooky tree?
Let's check out this one first.
Oh, I like this guy.
He's carrying the big old cross.
I like that.
Okay.
Can you hide in a corner?
I think that's where he comes from though, right?
Let's open the gate.
Alright.
Onwards.
I just got a game.
Oh my gosh.
Spooky.
Spooky, spooky, spooky.
What's in here?
Oh gosh.
I'm a what?
An angel?
You look like a lizard.
Little lizard person.
Oh my gosh.
I think I'm going to die.
It looks like a lizard person for real.
Interesting that it puts us back here.
Okay, I'll take it.
If I face the correct direction...
I think it would help.
I'm an angel.
Yeah, that kind of looks like a frog bird.
Get him.
Oh shoot.
Oh there he goes.
See ya.
Oh gosh.
Yeah, back away.
Sometimes I get them.
My...
Mine will answer?
Who will answer?
Violator?
Oh, violator.
Nobody was thrilled when I got pregnant.
Not even a little happy.
Something came out of my mouth.
Even my doctor seemed to be judging me.
Each time I'd leave the doctor's office, I'd see this strange woman across the street.
All she'd do is stare at me and smile.
No words.
Just a big, warm smile.
Somehow it made those visits a little more bearable.
After I lost the baby, I saw her again across the street from the doctor's.
Her smile was as big as ever, but somehow not as warm and friendly as I remember.
Yesterday I was walking and was shocked to see the woman standing in the middle of the path.
Now she was pregnant.
She beckoned towards me.
I followed her off the path into the woods.
That's when I met Gary.
Spooky.
Oh, it was that lady.
Alright, child.
Alright, let's go kick this kid's ass.
But he's such a little jerk.
Alright, ready?
Gun bear.
Oh my gosh, where did he come from?
Is he in the smoke or is he...
I think he's in the smoke.
Maybe he's...
Because he came out so fast.
Oh my gosh, that was... He's in the clouds.
Okay, okay.
So I have to watch which... Okay, this is gonna take me maybe a couple more times.
Sorry, guys.
Oh my gosh.
How do I tell...
I see... I don't see.
Oh, he's in this one.
Oh dang it!
I thought he would maybe...
Okay, okay, but I had it.
I had it.
I could see him.
I just needed to move.
Yeah, you can barely...
Very...
Barely see him.
Don't stand between the clouds, silly.
This kid sucks!
I think I can only stand between the clouds.
Mintus.
Okay.
Oh my goodness.
Gosh, where is he gonna go next?
Okay.
No.
Dang it.
Okay, maybe I can get him from here.
Oh shoot!
Oh my gosh, that was close.
I don't know which way he's gonna go from here.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, okay.
ViviCorne, thanks for the 5!
Gifted!
1, 2, 3, 4, 5!
5!
See ya, baby.
Losing grandpa was the hardest thing I ever experienced.
These games are so depressing.
We were really close.
I cried about it for weeks.
Then my stepmom introduced me to some of her friends.
They asked me, would you like to see your grandfather again?
I missed him so much I was willing to try anything.
That night, my stepmom drove me to one of her friends' house.
They took me down to the basement.
I saw my grandfather in there.
Only it wasn't actually him.
When I tried to run, they closed the basement door and locked me in!
I can't remember much else from that night.
My stepmom's friends are always coming by the house now.
They tell me I have a debt to pay.
They say...
They have work for me to do.
Oh my gosh.
They are headless now.
I watch only the freshest of herbs.
Wait, this thing has changed too.
I'm at the end though.
Do I have to...
Oh my gosh.
I'm bleeding out.
Wait, what's that thing in the corner?
That's not me, right?
No.
What should I draw with my blood?
M...
I...
T...
Minto.
And among us...
Okay, hold on.
It kind of has a big dumpy, but you can see...
I'll draw you guys too.
Oh wait, I forgot to draw your wispy self.
And then...
Your eyes.
Hold on, I'm just gonna extra bleed there.
Okay, now extra bleed here.
Okay, perfect.
And a big ol' smile.
And then...
The details.
It's you!
Solve the riddle of Gallop's ce...
Why do I keep saying ce...
Cemetery?
I can't.
I keep saying...
Oh, we can save.
Are we dead or...
It's like I'm saying celery.
Oh, we can save again.
Okay, cool.
Wait, I don't have to do all these things again, right?
Oh, they're headless.
Okay.
Let's go up.
Celery.
Cellophane.
Mr. Cellophane.
Should I change my name?
Cause they can look right through me.
Walk right by me.
They'll never know I'm there.
I never knew that guy was there either.
Damn tree!
Okay.
Oh, you!
Which tree is it?
You.
I guess, actually, maybe, okay.
Love seeing Mortis' phantom play Faith.
Ah!
Fish want her.
Confess thy sins.
I remember the trick to the candles.
Vaguely.
It's like where... The candles show where something is... In what room something is in.
I remember.
Very vaguely.
Day one of our paranormal investigation into the Old Snake Meadow Hill Church.
We've got three cameras, a box of tapes... Oh my god, wait.
Hold on.
Are you ghost hunters?
When I was a kid, I experienced the paranormal.
And now, I hunt the paranormal.
And it follows me in my everyday life.
I'm joined by my other investigators, Aaron and the other guy who nobody knows his name.
My name is Zack Baggins.
And these are our ghost adventures.
Day one of our paranormal investigation into the Old Snake Meadow Hill Church.
We've got three cameras, a box of tapes, and enough beer and beef jerky to last us a week.
On our way in, we asked some of the locals about the church.
It was mostly the stories we had heard before.
Evil spirits dragging children into the cornfield and secret tunnels under the chapel.
But there was this spindly lady game that we hadn't heard yet.
Apparently, it has to do with summoning the spirit of a woman who used to take care of the orphans back in the 50s.
There was even an old rhyme they told us.
Walk the church from room to room, and maybe you will see her.
But she will move when you do, but never try to trick her.
Okay, you can't rhyme her with her.
That's the same word.
Who came up with this rhyme?
It's not a rhyme.
You can't rhyme the same word next to each other.
It's not... It doesn't work like that.
Ghosts can't be critics.
Why not?
Awesome.
We are going to try the game tonight as soon as we get settled in.
So she is in this room somewhere?
Or... What room are we in?
We are in this one, right?
This one right here?
Why did the music stop?
Okay.
So now she is in... Oh no, I see.
We are... Okay, that's where we are.
We are that one.
Okay, I got it.
Night 3.
Shouldn't have come here.
Tapes missing.
Lars stuck behind basement door.
Henry hasn't come back yet.
Can't leave anyway.
Isn't there something in here?
Pray for me father, for I have sinned.
Let's see if you can do it like this.
I've sinned.
I tried to save a girl from evil, but my fears overcame me.
I turned my back on the ministry, and broke my vows to God.
A year later, the girl reached out to me again.
But in the end, I couldn't save her.
Couldn't save her.
I left her to die.
I am sorry for me and my past sins.
I don't like that.
Why is Palpatine in there?
Where are we?
Be gone evil Mona Lisa.
Night 1.
We still haven't found a way into the basement, but we found something just as cool.
A secret passage in the old confession booth leading to this hallway.
Henry is going into town to buy a crowbar.
We'll see if we can get these boards off of some of these doors.
But that's not even the best part.
We caught an EVP.
An electronic voice phenomenon.
That's what EVP is.
You can't hear it on tape very well, but to us it kind of sounded like laughing.
Thank God we brought the nice mic.
No, everybody knows you bring the really terrible mics.
They all bring the same mics.
Did you guys know that they all bring the same mics from like the mid 2000s?
That like everything is so static-y.
So even if you hear like a...
It sounds on the tape.
It sounds like a ghost being like, I will kill you.
You know?
And then they'll be like, whoa.
Did that ghost just say spaghetti?
They all do that.
We'll review it on the sound gear once we get back into town.
Okay, so we're in this room.
The secret room.
What about this one?
Is this a death?
Nope.
Can't go in for some reason.
Nevermind.
Is someone gonna come out though?
Is someone gonna come out?
Okay, nevermind.
Oh, we might be able to meet with her.
In the middle right here.
Oh lady.
So are we hearing men through EVP?
Basically, but...
I sound nice and crisp, don't I?
Oh dang it, she's in this room.
Do you think she'll move?
Something's here.
Oh gosh.
Boo.
Do you talk about weird ghost hunters with other ghosts?
Sometimes, yeah, actually.
Lady, where are you?
Spin, spindly lady.
Something's here.
I know, I know, I know.
Where?
Oh my gosh, she scared the heck out of me.
Oh my gosh.
Oh gosh.
I'm gonna die.
Oh my god.
I didn't get to kill her.
Oh shoot.
I'm gonna...
Oh my god.
Lady, give me a good angle please.
Give me a good angle.
Here we go.
I got a little bit in at least.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Lady, you're too spindly.
Oh, I was looking the wrong direction.
Oh.
Drive by.
Drive by cross.
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no.
She's gonna kill me for real.
Nice.
Did she say heretic?
Yay!
Drive by crossing.
What's this?
Big cross.
Watch the candles.
You're too late.
Oh my gosh.
I already figured out the puzzle.
Gosh.
I already knew.
I'm smarter than these stupid ghosts.
Watch the candies?
Wait.
Candies?
I thought it said candles.
Oh, they won't come back down.
It says candles, you guys.
I can't read.
Same thing.
Candies.
Well, we haven't looked around the other rooms, so let's do that real quick.
Oh.
Night 2.
We're gonna be rich.
We've caught supernatural stuff on Chaos.
Sorry, I thought they were saying they caught it.
The design of the Spiggly Lady was selected as the winner for the developer's open character design contest announced before the full version of Chapter 2 was released back in 2018.
Oh, really?
Guys, candy, because it's almost Halloween.
We've caught supernatural stuff on camera before, sure.
Doors opening on their own, things falling off of shelves, but nothing like this.
Tonight, while we were trying the Spiggly Lady game again, one of the candles on the floor lit up by itself as soon as Lars walked into the room.
It was nuts, and we got it all on film.
We're gonna make a fortune selling this to the TV stations.
Aw, man.
Silly ghost hunters.
Usually, though, for ghost hunters and stuff...
Like, we just don't want to be bossed around, you know?
And they're just like, show yourself.
No, it makes me not want to show myself.
You know?
Like, I'm quietly dead.
Living, or not really living, but like, you know, enjoying my quiet, dead afterlife.
And you come into my cafe, and you're just like...
Say something.
You say something.
You tellin' me to?
Yeah, that's what I'm sayin'.
So, you know...
Darkness surrounds thee.
Oh, reach the basement of Snake Meadow Hill Church.
Who's watching me now?
But sometimes it is fun to mess with them, you know?
To mess with the ghost hunters.
And do something silly.
New ghost hunter trick.
Ask the ghost about metal gear.
But that only works for me.
That only works for me.
I wonder if there's any other ghosts that like metal gear.
I would like to be their friend.
This is my final memoir.
Hastily scribbled on a page of the good book.
I now descend the staircase knowing full well that she waits for me ahead.
Checking my old watch has revealed something quite astonishing.
Time doesn't change down here as we know it on the surface.
Even now, the hands don't move past two.
Give us a sign, Minto.
Ghost hunters sound like a pain to deal with.
How much could ghost pelts and ghost meat possibly sell for?
Like, is it a lot?
Could you live off of it?
Ghost pelts?
Ghost meat?
The good book?
Lord of the Rings?
No, no.
They mean my doujin collection.
God's work be done.
I have been to where only the faintest light shine to protect from things unspeakable.
God help me, Father Clark, a foolish old man going mad in this dark prison.
Ears bleeding from the screams of the demon.
I don't know what any of that means.
Am I gonna have to remember this?
Gosh, I don't remember.
Any ghost bones?
Any haunted bones here?
I think my chat is screwed up again, you guys.
I'm really sorry.
Oh gosh, I can't leave here.
Wait, hold on.
My chat... YouTube is so bad recently.
I don't know why.
Like, it just keeps freezing on me.
Basically, every stream.
I don't get it.
It's actually so frustrating.
It freezes on me and then when I go to the YouTube site, it doesn't load anything.
So it's just... Oh, it's the worst.
It's terrible.
Okay, we're back, baby.
We're back.
Can I read that again?
No.
Okay.
Oh shoot.
Guys, I...
I think I'm gonna die.
Mortis.
Let's see.
YouTube has been kind of terrible recently.
I know.
Okay, so...
Oh gosh.
So...
This is a lot.
Um...
Think clock.
I'd screenshot it.
Remember the note.
Wait, I just got rid of the note.
Notes.
Davies.
Oh, this note is missing?
Okay.
Note 9-3.
Paranormal investigation.
Why isn't it in order?
No!
Father Garcia.
Wait, no.
No.
Wait, it is in order.
It is in order.
Ah!
Here we go.
This is my final memoir hastily scribbled on the page of the good book.
Checking my old watch has revealed something quite astonishing.
Time doesn't change down here as if...
Oh, it doesn't move past 2.
So maybe I need to go to the one that is like 2 PM.
Which would be...
That kanji radical.
Yeah, the H.
The H.
Maybe 3?
Would it be the X or the H?
I guess we'll figure it out.
This one.
Then there was this one.
This was 3.
Keep following the clock.
Oh gosh, I don't remember what was after.
I think you have to look at the patterns after H.
Is it upside down dirt?
Or Uzumaki?
Let's go to this one.
Oh, I did it.
I was correct.
Is it clock?
Or is it deadpool?
If you get it wrong, just go back to the entrance of the room.
Arrows.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, heretic.
Is it funny dancey forks?
Or tiny house?
Oh, is it Uzumaki now?
Then we go to flower?
Do I just go this way?
Mother of demons!
I like these guys.
They are so fun.
Oh my gosh, we made it outside!
We came from a porta potty!
I almost got trampled by a deer for real.
Thanks for the help with the clock puzzle guys.
Three murdered in latest wave of ritualistic killings.
Sterling, Connecticut.
The bodies of three young people were discovered in the woods outside of Sterling last night.
And what authorities are calling a ritualistic murder!
Sandra Atwood, Angel Nogales, and Troy Inglis.
Are the names of the unfortunate victims who were apparently stabbed multiple times and beheaded before being killed in a paganistic ritual.
Do you think those are the three people that I fought in the cemetery?
Pandemonium Regnet.
Nat.
Two of the victims' bodies were also partially burned, although authorities would not specify who.
The bodies were found several miles from Gallop Cemetery, where residents reported a tomb had been desecrated.
Yeah, so maybe...
How do I say your name?
Thank you for three bars!
Thank you, thank you!
Chaos Reigns.
They also found trails of blood leading off into the woods.
Investigators would not comment on whether or not these two incidents could be related.
The arrangement of the bodies in the ritualistic pattern, as well as the writing of certain symbols and blood, matches the style of several murders that have occurred in the Sterling area since 1986.
I think we have... I think... I think there's...
I don't... What is that?
I don't know how to say that word.
You're looking hauntingly bootiful tonight.
Thank you, Brian!
Just seeing you raises my spirits!
What is this?
The killings may have connected to last week's brutal slaying of Amy Martin.
Wait, slaying?
We didn't kill her though.
Thank you, thank you!
I'm gifted!
A 17-year-old girl by John Ward.
Ward had impersonated a priest to gain Amy's trust before luring her into the woods and killing her.
No!
We didn't do that!
We didn't do... I mean...
It was like the last ending we did, but...
But we did the...
We did the...
Investigators are asking residents to report any suspicious activity to the police.
Authorities are urging the people of Sterling to not mourn the loss of Atwood, Nogales, and Inglis...
...Inglis, because after all, they were degenerate devil-worshipping thugs who were hooked on crack cocaine and hated their parents.
Why even conduct an investigation at all?
That's what you would like them to think, wouldn't you, John?
Oh my gosh!
They were just three pathetic outcasts who got what they deserved.
You actually did the community a favor when you found them getting high in... that tomb.
Sorry, I'm a demon, but I have, like, a bit of a stutter.
Sorry!
Oh my god, how embarrassing.
Um, okay, back to scary.
You stalked them through the graves and killed them one by one.
You ignored their cries for help, their pleas for mercy.
You put holes in their ruined, drug-addict bodies.
And then you chopped off their heads because everybody knows that removing the head is the only way to kill a snake.
Whoa!
And guess what?
You didn't kill the snake, John.
You cannot kill what you cannot be killed.
Thou shalt not raise up what thou shalt...
Wait, hold on.
One more time.
Thou shalt not raise up what thou canst not put down again.
Thou couldst not... couldnst not kill Amy.
Thou shalt not destroy my works, for they are the works of the eternal dragon.
Even now she is at thy door.
Her hand is at thy throat.
Yet you see her not.
I will have thy soul, for I am the god of this world.
This is kind of doing it for me.
Brother, please.
Get some help.
Oh my god.
Oh, there's more.
PANDEMONIUM.
REGNOT SATANI.
RETIRE PANDEMONIUM.
Oh, there's more.
It kind of looks like it says pregnant.
PARGON.
SICK.
Yeah, the devil's number.
I am here, John.
I'm a little spider guy now!
Woo!
Party, party!
If I were a spider, where would I go?
I'd go this way.
Okay.
Up the water spout?
Oh!
You were right!
Up the water spout.
Down came the rain and washed the spider out.
Hey, fellows!
Wait, why is there an arrow that points down?
I don't want to be a spider again.
Try left?
Wait, can I actually?
Like, from here?
Go on left?
No,
nothing happens.
So, let's go down.
I guess because it's pointing that way.
Oh no, their car is broken down.
That sucks so much.
I can go help him out.
Hey guys, I'm a good mechanic.
Okay, I'm really slow up this hill though.
Okay, I'm a person who needs to work out a bit more.
John?
I can't even get up the hill.
Nevermind.
Okay, nevermind.
It's a bad ending thing.
So you'll be good.
Wait, going up there is a bad ending?
Oh, I should have been a little spider.
And then I could have been like...
I see.
I should have never...
Candy Tunnel!
You guys were right about the candy!
What did it say?
Watch the candy?
Death awaits.
Oh, enter Candy Tunnel.
This looks like...
It's not... No, from here it looks like... Okay, do you guys know the club Mogra?
From here it looks like the Mogra symbol.
Here it's an eyeball.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, can't do that.
Yeah, the Mogra logo.
Oh, scary.
Does that say snake?
Oh god, is something coming after me or is it just ambiance?
Okay, so...
Hey now, you're an ale star.
Oh my gosh, this is a man!
Multiple officers wounded.
One dead in sewer tunnel shootout.
Law enforcement officials are reporting multiple officers down, including one deputy who was fatally wounded after an exchange of gunfire in the sewer tunnels near Snake Meadow Hill Road, also known as the Candy Tunnel.
Why do we call it the Candy Tunnel?
It has such a cheerful name.
Give it a new tunnel... Give it a new name...
All the kids are going to be heading to Candy Tunnel otherwise.
Witnesses say they heard the shots approximately 10 minutes after police raided the tunnels, where suspected murderers Joe Bauman, aka the Candy Store Killer, was alleged to be hiding.
At this time, it is not known how many officers have been wounded.
Although it has been confirmed that one officer has been killed.
Officials are not saying if Bauman was wounded in the exchange, and efforts are being made to recover the casualties from the tunnels.
Have a nice night, Minto!
Early morning tomorrow here.
Have a good night, Senshi!
I hope that you don't have to wake up... Well, you have to wake up early, but hopefully you don't feel tired about it, you know?
Hey, what's that little red thing over there?
Hello?
Are you going to run at me?
S-Satin lives.
I spelled Satan wrong.
No, they just really love to sew.
They're just like, yeah, satin is like the best fabric, baby!
Akui?
What does Akui mean?
Let's go to Candy Tunnel, Charlie!
No!
Two more dead discovered outside Candy Tunnel near Sterling.
Two more bodies have been recovered from the drainage ditch under Snake Meadow Hill Road outside Sterling.
Sorry.
The notorious Candy Tunnel, known in the area to be home to addicts, gangs, runaways, and the indigent...
...has been the site of several grisly discoveries over the past three months.
Since May, five bodies have been recovered from the drainage ditch leading to the tunnels.
I think we just need to, like...
Okay, I think we just need to, like, silent hill this city and then forget it ever exists, you know?
Let's just, like, remove it from the map and...
Let's just, you know...
Oh my gosh.
Let's just, like...
What's another thing?
Let's discover something under the ground that will poison the city and force everybody to move.
Easy peasy.
Silent hill the entire Connecticut?
No, it's just this snake meadow hill area, I think.
Casual villain talk.
No, this town is the villain.
It's the whole town.
Authorities are being pressured by concerned citizens to search the tunnels.
Amid fears of a possible connection to Joe Bauman, aka the candy store killer, who has claimed eight victims in Connecticut and Rhode Island...
Oh, time to get rid of Rhode Island too.
Over the past year.
What does Akui mean?
Oh, wait, how did I...
Huh?
The game wraps around so weird.
It means here.
Oh.
So here.
Nothing.
Nothing, eh?
Can't tell what the other doodles are.
It's pronounced Aki.
Oh, thank you.
Wait, oh my gosh, how am I getting so lost now?
This is so strange.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Now that I... I can't go back to the beginning.
Maybe I can here?
No, I can't go back to the beginning anymore.
Oh my gosh, this is so weird.
I'm lost.
Yeah, it's looping in a really weird way.
There they go.
I don't have a way to get through there yet.
Nope.
It's pretty spooky down... Read.
Okay.
Read what?
Read the signs?
Oh.
When see.
Don't... I'm scared.
Hey now, you're an L star, get your game on, go play.
When you see it, don't move.
It
told me to move.
Oh gosh.
Does that say snake up there?
It's my type of graffiti.
Oh my gosh.
Oh god.
Mother.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, we can go through here though.
Where?
How?
Which direction?
Can I go this way?
No.
Interesting.
Just came from the walls.
Oh, I can go this way.
Pero?
Here we go.
Up the tunnel.
What does pelo mean?
I'm scared.
Yeah, I clipped through the wall.
Hair?
I mean, the ghosts have been very, like, hairy.
Oh, it's saved.
Is there anything over here?
Maybe not.
Oh goodness.
What does this say?
Oh, I'm sorry.
God, please save me.
There is no saving you.
This place looks friendly.
Mostly body hair.
Head hair is cabelo.
Okay, so we got this mouth.
Looks really friendly.
Okay.
Let's go this way.
Check out this area.
Let's follow the blood.
Always a good idea.
Every horror movie protagonist does this.
Oh.
Do I have to?
Oh, cabelo.
Sorry.
I'm so sorry.
You guys are like, no Mint, please.
What is that anyway?
Oh, it's a flashlight.
Oh god.
Oh my god, no.
Oh god, I think I'm dead.
Where are you?
There are children!
I can't...
Shit!
Oh my god.
You can't catch me?
Party!
Oh my god.
Suffer with my...
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Oh shit, he's gone.
Oh shoot.
Oh shoot, he's gone.
Where?
I did it!
Holy moly!
Yippee!
Maybe just a little more speed, John boy, for real.
John is so casual about this.
He's just like...
I'll mosey along, I suppose.
The party is up here, baby.
Can we get like a save after that, please?
Thank you.
Game.
Oh gosh.
I don't...I don't like this.
I wish I had not just flashlight.
Why is it so dark?
Teehee?
Oh I think he said he is here, actually.
Teehee!
He is here.
Oh!
Crash your party.
Enter the hidden sanctum.
Oh my gosh.
I don't like this at all.
They hate the light.
Got it.
I hate this whole concept.
I really don't like it.
Oh gosh.
Ok.
Let's...Oh, oh, oh.
Oh shoot.
Oh god.
Oh they are everywhere.
Hey, back off, back off, back off ladies.
Back off ladies, please.
I'm busy.
Oh god.
Back off ladies!
Oh my god.
I'm almost dead.
Ok.
Is anybody in here?
There is children running everywhere.
Why can't I grab the key?
Oh I got it.
Ok.
Oh my goodness.
The ladies love you.
I know.
They can't keep their hands off of me, apparently.
I don't want to have to redo this.
Oh.
What's this?
I can't get to it yet.
I have to...
Ok.
Purple child.
Oh my gosh.
The three things for the bad end.
I see the spider.
And then...
Not sure what the child is.
And then something to do.
Ok.
I see, I see, I see.
I have to find three secrets to open that.
Interesting.
Oh gosh!
Oh my god, this kid.
Leave me alone.
Please.
Ok, I have to go back through here, which is going to be really annoying, but...
Please, leave me.
I'm just going to run for it.
And go.
Back, back.
Be gone.
I did it!
Anything, anything here?
Oh my god!
There they are!
Father Garcia!
I'm really...
It's like...
It's like basically like...
One of those quests, you know?
One of those missions.
Escort missions.
Ok, Father Garcia.
You speak.
I'll do the work.
Maybe.
I'll do my best at least.
Ok, you can't really...
Ok, hold on.
Can I trust you?
Ok, I think you're safe.
Yeah, I know.
Let us go.
Thanks father.
Amen to that.
Oh boy.
Ok, it's saved.
Cool rotoscoping cutscene.
Oh goodness.
Yeah!
Hey,
back off!
Back off!
This is like paparazzi training.
I know Father Garcia is really sought after.
Oh my goodness.
Don't move around Father Garcia, please!
Yeah, two birds with one stone, baby!
Back off!
I'm the bodyguard!
Back off everybody!
Yeah, yeah!
Back off!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I know you want to touch his hand.
You want to get his autograph.
He's busy.
He's reciting something.
He's got a lot of words, ok?
Let him finish his speech everybody.
His little monologue...
Oh shoot.
Oh no, I don't like this.
Father?
Father!
Father, I'm scared.
Father, where did you go?
Father!
Father, I am scared.
Father, help me.
Father, where did you go?
I don't like the music.
Oh my gosh.
That was so close guys.
Holy moly, that was so close.
Sorry I can't really reach out right now guys, but I'm fighting for my afterlife here.
Well, really John's life.
Oh my gosh.
Ok, yep, we're doing it John.
We got her?
Oh shoot.
Run!
Nice!
Oh, I don't know what this means.
Oh my gosh.
Get out of the way father!
Father!
Father, get out of the way!
Father, she's coming.
Father, she's doing something.
Oh my god.
Father.
Father, you need to get out of the way please.
Father is daring.
Yeah, for real.
We got her?
Oh gosh.
Exploding!
Thank you!
Welcome to Mambo Ship!
Oh god.
Out of the way!
Father, please!
You're scaring me!
How are you living?
Phase 2?
The morning breaks.
Oh we did it?
First try!
Yahoo!
We gamed!
John, I can't do this anymore.
I'm sorry.
I will always love you back.
Molly.
Let's just tuck that away in there.
Oh Molly.
I keep your pillow.
Just smell it.
Molly, Molly, Molly, Molly.
I'm just a simple priest with a boy in my basement.
Or in this room I guess.
Holy moly.
First try baby.
John, we don't have much time.
The profane Sabbath is almost upon us.
If they find Nate and Jason, they will perform a ritual on them to call forth a demon of unspeakable power.
The name of the demon is...
Malphas.
I am in the process of discovering their whereabouts.
I will contact you again soon.
We must not let them do what the boys... Wait.
Do to the boys what they did to Amy.
Father Garcia.
Make that a habit.
Wait, wait.
I don't know this demon.
The boys!
Stopped.
Faith!
Wait, where is the rain of spiders?
Is it in the third part?
Yeah, it's in the third part.
I'm sorry David.
Survive the nightmare.
Oh my gosh, we got the ending one.
Go forth with faith.
How many endings are in this one?
Yeah, rain of spiders are in the third chapter.
It's on the last boss.
New backgrounds, new effect unlocked, new play mode unlocked.
Nice.
And guys, that was Faith chapters 1 and 2.
I went for the last chapters.
Or rather, I went for... Sorry, I went for all endings of chapter 1 because they were pretty easy to get.
But, how easy is it to get the other... I mean, I feel like I have to go way back in chapter 2.
And like, do stuff, you know.
When ending is more complicated.
It's a lot harder, yeah.
It's like a little bit more effort than I'm willing to put in, today at least.
Ending 2, you can let Garcia die.
Yeah, but then I have to do the final boss all over again, and I gamed!
Chapter 3 of True Ending is very worth getting.
Basically play the whole chapter, seriously.
But, we gamed.
We gamed in that final boss fight.
I don't know how he lived.
He was like, just standing in the middle of it.
He was just like...
He was like, yeah, I guess I'll stand in this pentagram.
He was probably like Matrix dodging.
He was going so fast, we couldn't even tell though.
His faith is strong.
Gosh, we all need to be more like him.
Like Father Garcia.
That was fun.
I can't remember how long it took me the first time I played these.
For the first two chapters.
But, I think I went faster than I did before.
I don't know, actually I can't tell.
Maybe I was about the same.
I like to walk around.
Well, I did talk a lot at the very beginning of the stream.
I talked a lot.
I was like on the first note of the game.
I was literally on the instructions and just yapping away.
Excited for 3.0.
Thank you, Kasha.
Bro, thank you.
Definitely feels faster.
Tri-princess, thank you.
Ducky, thanks for the bomb gifter.
I offer a prayer that your 3.0 debut goes well for you.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
So excited.
I'm like, I wanted to obviously come so much quicker.
But, obviously I have so much that needs to be finished too.
So, not too fast.
Not too fast.
I did tell the people, my team.
I have two teams that I'm working with on stuff.
And for one of them, I was like, if you guys need me to delay the debut, I will.
But, you know, it's kind of sad because I chose Halloween.
But, if I have to, I would.
It's just...
Hopefully, I don't have to.
But, I would much rather have their health over a date.
You know, that I want for my debut.
You know what I mean?
So, I think I talked about this before on stream.
Maybe it was a member's stream.
I can't remember.
No, I think it was just a normal stream.
But, I was like, you know.
Because one of the artists had some health issues.
I was like, girl, just tell me.
I will delay it.
I will just pretend it's Halloween.
Like, two days later or something.
I don't know.
So...
Yeah.
Minto is anti-crunch.
I just...
It's just...
I don't know.
It's just not...
It wouldn't be worth it.
I would feel so bad.
We'll see what they say closer to the date, so...
But, I will have some special guests.
During my...
During the debut.
Some special people recorded things for me.
So...
I'm still waiting on three recordings.
But, if they happen and they happen.
If they don't, that's okay too.
Everybody's busy.
But, I'll announce...
Who the guests are...
Closer to the date.
There was one guest I really wanted.
But...
I...
Don't think there's enough time.
I will try for a future thing.
But...
Kiwawa.
Lilac.
Oh my god.
David Hayter.
You'll have to come to the debut to find out.
Thank you!
Chapter 2.
Awesome.
First try was impressive.
Nice gaming, Minto.
And thanks for the laughs today.
3.01 week to go.
Hype!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Kojima.
Yeah.
You'll have to see it.
I heard of people hanging Christmas decorations weeks ago.
I think it's fair that you can extend Halloween if you need to.
I went to the store and there was already a Christmas section.
I was so angry.
I was like, excuse me?
They had advent calendars and stuff.
I was like, no, no, no.
Not yet.
They can't even wait for Halloween day to pass.
It's so frustrating.
It's not over yet.
Christmas.
I saw Christmas stuff in September.
That's insane.
And then Spirit Halloween will turn into Spirit Christmas.
It's not going to be...
It's not going to feel the same.
Spirit Christmas.
I love...
I went to a Spirit Halloween the other day.
Because I was just like, I want to feel like it's Halloween.
So I just went inside.
And like saw the...
Oh my gosh.
They had...
What's that new...
That new...
The third movie of it just came out.
Mariah Carey is coming to thaw out your new model.
That's me.
I'm Mariah Carey.
Oh, Terrifier.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Terrifier.
Art the Clown.
Is that his name?
I too saw giant Christmas displays in September in Costco.
Infuriating.
That's the worst.
Can I hit the high notes?
Oh, Mariah Carey's high notes?
If I warmed up maybe.
I...
Will have to do a Christmas karaoke then.
I work at a grocery store and corporate already put up Christmas decor.
It's so sad.
Thanks for spooky time intel.
By the way, I asked David Kaye to sing you the MGS5 version of Happy Birthday.
But I don't think he knew what it was.
Where's the shot?
Oh!
I want to watch that.
Wait, hold on.
Sorry.
I actually didn't finish.
I watched just a tiny bit of it.
Okay, barn.
And then I was like, oh, I want to watch the rest of it on stream.
So you can get my real reaction.
Hold on, let me...
Let me...
Find it.
Oh my gosh.
You guys, I know you like lilac.
But try not to be so mean about it.
When you do stuff like this.
Hold on.
This is so mean.
I just went to my tag.
My art tag.
I see stuff like this.
Like this is just mean.
This is just mean.
Don't be rude.
Don't be like...
Oh, lilac is so much better than mint.
Don't be rude.
Okay, about it.
I know that you guys like...
It makes me feel like you don't like how I look.
It makes me so sad.
It makes me feel like you guys think I'm ugly.
Don't be so rude about it.
Okay.
Don't be so mean.
My feelings.
I'm a sensitive...
I'm a sensitive ghost.
Okay.
One second.
Hold on.
Let me change this.
Wait, how do I change?
Hold on.
Wait.
Why is...
Why is Twitter the way that it is?
It's just so...
It's so bad.
Oh, here we go.
Okay.
Let me pull it up.
Mint is my favorite.
Thank you.
I think it's just getting to me because it's so...
You know, at first I was just like...
And then it became so many things where it's like...
Lilac is cuter than mint.
Oh, lilac is better than mint.
And I'm like...
But I'm mint!
What about valley girl demon?
Oh my god.
Are you like obsessed with me?
That's like so crazy.
You can't be obsessed with a demon.
Do you want to like make a contract with me?
Oh my god.
Okay.
So, you just got to sign your name on the line.
And then I can make like a wish come true.
But then I get your soul.
Whoa.
Okay, but that's not like until you die.
Which could be tomorrow.
But you don't know.
You have to live your life to the fullest.
Like while you can.
Okay?
Live every life.
Every day.
Like you signed over your soul to a demon.
And you have to live it to the fullest.
Because once you die, I will get your soul.
And then like...
It'll be miserable.
And you'll be burning in hell for all of eternity.
Crazy.
But like, for real.
Do you want to make a contract with me?
Okay.
Where do I sign?
You're so crazy.
Oh my gosh.
Josh, you're so wacky.
It's Josh's era right now.
Do you need this in blood or...
Whatever.
Yeah, probably in blood.
Is what they want.
Yeah.
Cool.
Yeah, probably.
Yeah.
Is that okay?
Just a little finger prick.
Just like that.
You know?
Just a little...
It like barely hurts.
But for me, I'm going to pass out if I look at it.
So like, don't do it in front of me.
I'll like turn around and close my eyes.
You tell me when you're done.
Okay?
I wish for a hold...
Wait.
Hat?
Oh my gosh.
I can't believe I messed that up.
I can't like...
I can't like even read.
I wish for hand holding with Minto.
That's like so lewd, Brian.
Wow.
You belong in hell.
Oh my God.
You're going there for sure.
What a degenerate.
Oh my gosh.
I can't believe you typed that on the internet.
Wow.
Why are you so good at this?
Because it's like...
Me.
Okay.
This is like who I am.
So...
It's suspiciously good.
I've only like made like...
I don't know.
Like three, four hundred contracts or something.
You know?
Like whatever.
People are just so willing to like...
I don't know.
I think I'm just charismatic.
It's like...
I go up to people and I'm like...
You want to make a contract?
And they're like...
Oh, she seems nice.
And I'm like...
I know.
I am so nice.
I'm like the nicest demon they'll ever meet.
And then they just sign their name.
They're like...
I didn't read the fine print.
And I'm like...
It's fine.
You know?
Eternity in hell.
Whatever.
Blah blah blah.
Fire.
Whatever.
You're like...
Hanging from your toenails.
All that fun stuff in hell.
Crazy!
It's kind of exciting though if you've never tried it before.
But...
You know.
It's like...
Just kind of one of those things.
Anyway.
Right?
Crazy!
So crazy.
Father Garcia is shaking.
That's because he like...
Knows how real I am.
I'm like...
In my realist era of demonhood.
Demon girls!
We're crazy!
We're like...
Oh my gosh.
I got a pumpkin spice latte.
And I went...
Wow!
Spicy!
For the season!
What's your insta?
Oh my gosh.
You're trying to get my gram?
I don't know.
I don't really like...
I feel like...
You know.
When I go on hikes.
And when I eat babies sometimes.
Like...
Just the normal demon things.
It's all boring.
You don't want it.
You don't want my instagram?
Wow.
What's an infernal patron?
Wait.
With...
I can't even read.
Gosh.
Sorry guys.
I'm so kooky.
With an infernal patron this kooky.
How could I not sign?
That's what I'm saying.
Like I said.
Just to think of it as like...
Like a vacation.
That lasts forever.
It's like really hot.
But just think of it like...
Florida.
Wow.
Disney.
Miami.
I always wanted to go to Miami.
Because of CSI.
Valley girl de momento I am most enamored with thee and have come to ask her hand in marriage.
I offer thee this green soup.
Green like the highlands.
Okay but like...
I can't really do anything with marriage.
It's like not really my thing.
Unless it's like an unholy marriage.
the whole holy thing is kind of a drag.
I can't really do that.
You know what I mean?
Because I'm a demon.
It's just kind of...
Yeah.
You know.
But if you like sign this contract with your blood.
It could be like a thing.
It's just not marriage.
It's just a contract.
Basically the same thing.
You know?
What's with the salt?
Tasty.
Om nom nom nom.
I'm actually trying to watch my salt intake.
I went to like the demonologist the other day.
And they were like, Whoa girly.
You are having way too many fries lately.
And I'm like, Okay doctor.
Like I know.
I need to watch my figure.
I need to watch my salt intake.
I'm like not a carb girl right now.
Okay.
So.
Yeah.
I have to not eat all the salt.
Sorry.
Thanks for offering though.
Gonna slide into your DMs.
AKA demon messages.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
Turns off my DMs.
Thank you.
Okay.
I think I'm done with this bit.
Is that okay?
Is it alright if I like end this bit and watch the thing?
Oh.
I was gonna watch this.
Hold on.
Window.
Capture.
There we go.
Wait.
Let's crop more.
Make bigger.
There we go.
Okay.
Yay!
Kvarn got this cameo for me for my birthday.
But I never saw it until today.
And so we're gonna watch it.
And I didn't watch the whole thing.
So I'm very excited.
I watched like a couple seconds of it.
So I'm excited.
Okay.
Here we go!
Mint, David K.
Wars.
Maybe you might better recognize this character.
Beast Wars Megatron.
Okay, this is where I watched up to.
So without further ado...
It's your birthday.
It was!
From the Wisps and myself.
Happy birthday to you.
Yes!
Happy birthday dear Mint.
A good Predacon name.
Happy birthday to you.
Have a great one.
It doesn't say how old you are.
I imagine you're 21.
21!
But anyway.
Cool.
Have a great day on your birthday.
Thank you!
And thank you the Wisps for allowing me to do this.
And this is just a peek into the studio.
I'm gonna do my work this morning.
It looks like I have to do some work right now.
Some work.
So I gotta get back to it.
Anyway, thank you again.
Have a great birthday.
Thank you!
Excellent.
Yes.
Thanks David Kaye!
Wait, hold on.
I have to hear it again.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Mint.
A good Predacon name.
Happy birthday to you.
Yes.
Have a great one.
It doesn't say how old.
Predacon name.
Happy birthday to you.
Yes.
To you.
Have a great one.
Thank you Kaye-boy!
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
I wanna watch Beast Wars so bad right now.
Thank you!
OK, I'm gonna go now guys.
Thank you for hanging out with me today for Faze.
We'll finish.
We'll do the third game next week.
Before Halloween.
Beast Wars watch-along?
Should we?
It's hard to find though.
I don't...
I think I first watched it on Netflix.
Titles misleading?
Minto is still an angel?
No, I went to heaven and then I left.
Thank you!
Thanks for the fun streams of these great games.
Next week is Raid of Spiders with those cuties.
Thank you!
Beasties!
Oh my gosh, we should do a Beast Wars watch-along.
It's kinda long though, isn't it?
We're in outer heaven now.
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
I had so much fun!
And I'll see you tomorrow.
Maybe?
Watch-along I'm begging you.
Tomorrow is...
Oh!
The DLC of Spooky's Mansion.
Spooky's...Spooky's...Pop-up...Spooky's...Spooky Mansion.
I finally am getting around to the DLC after I played the game so, so long ago.
I said that I would play it during Spooky Month and I'm upholding my end of the deal, baby.
Can we get a little spoiler on the time slot?
We need to save that day.
I'm excited.
Literally can't wait to see your new form.
Time slot?
Time slot.
For my 3.0?
There's a waiting room.
Yeah, Gliss, there's a waiting room.
That is already up.
So...
Yeah.
Yeah, for the debut.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a waiting room already up.
So you can already go see the time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, right.
Yeah, it's not gonna be so long probably.
So, maybe like two hours because I have the reveal and then some other stuff after.
Yeah.
So, you know, it's not gonna be like a whole day event or anything like that.
Thank you guys.
See you tomorrow or when I see you next.
Itterasshai!
Bye-bye!
Take care of yourselves, OK?
Mortis.